today on the matt walsh show the biden
administration takes its cue from orwell
setting up its very own ministry of
truth we'll discuss and a judicial
nominee admits during a confirmation
hearing that her previous claims about
police violence were untrue but made
made anyway for rhetorical purposes she
says plus joe biden continues to
mentally decay on camera ilhan omar
speaks out for student loan forgiveness
and our daily cancellation will examine
a video which purports to scientifically
prove the validity of transgenderism i'm
skeptical but i'll hear him out all of
that and more today on the matt wells
show
[Applause]
[Music]
did you know that if you're currently on
a phone plan with one of the major
carriers you are helping these
left-leaning companies donate to
pro-choice causes and candidates a
common question i get from my listeners
is what can i do to help turn the tides
in the culture more well here's a great
first step defund the abortionist don't
let them take your money and use it to
further policies you don't believe in
switch to charity mobile today and
they'll send you five percent they'll
send five percent of your monthly plan
price to a pro-life pro family charity
of your choice charity mobile offers the
latest 5g phones with no device or
service contracts plus they've got great
nationwide coverage so it's a great
service and also it's a company you can
believe in best of both worlds this
sounds like a hassle to make the change
i assure you it is and charity mobile
makes switching from your current
carrier pain list their live customer
service is exceptional it will provide
you
and guide you all throughout the process
you can keep your number and even in
most cases you can keep your phone or if
you want you can take advantage of my
special offer and get a free cell phone
free activation all you have to do is
call
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com and mention offer
code walsh to redeem the free cell phone
offer that's charitymobile.com and
mention offer code walsh join the fight
for the life of children by switching to
charity mobile today
you know orwell analogies are terribly
overused these days but there's a
there's a reason for that well there's
two reasons one is that 1984 is one of
about three books that the average
american has actually read all the way
through the other two are harry potter
books but the second reason is that so
much of what we're experiencing today
really was prophesied by orwell in 1984
and even more so in my opinion in this
allegory animal farm things tend to
happen that even a more widely read
person cannot help but compare to one of
those two works and what else are we
supposed to do when the bite
administration as they did this week
literally creates a ministry of truth
sure i mean they aren't calling it that
of course instead they they've come up
with an even more orwellian name than
what orwell chose their name is the
disinformation governance board now this
new board will exist within
the department of homeland security a
department that shouldn't exist and uh
which has since its conception been
responsible for many of the federal
government's most insidious civil rights
abuses yet another reason to thank
george w bush for his contributions to
massively expanding the federal
government
um the head of this new board is a
leftist ideologue an activist named nina
jankowitz who proudly announced her new
position in a tweet yesterday which you
can see here she posted here's my
official portrait to grab your attention
now that i've got it a huge focus of our
work and indeed one of the key reasons
the board was established is to maintain
the department's commitment to
protecting free speech privacy civil
rights
and civil liberties and then for
whatever reason she includes a photo of
quentin tarantino
the interesting thing to note about this
nina character is that
she's not only a leftist but also and
these two things often come together as
a package deal
uh of course completely insane as
evidenced by this video which has been
making the rounds since tucker carlson
played it on a show last night but if
you didn't see it
i think it's worth watching because this
again this is a woman who's going to be
at the department of homeland security
in charge of
disinformation
and here's what she's all about
information laundering is really quite
ferocious it's when a hopster takes some
lies and makes them sound precocious by
saying them in congress or a mainstream
outlet so disinformation's origins are
slightly less atrocious
it's how you hide a delighted lie it's
how you hide a little light a little lie
it's how you hide a little idol's lie
when rudy giuliani shared that intel
from ukraine or when tick tock
influences take over it can cause pain
they're laundering to sinful when we
really should take note and not support
their lives with our wallet
[Music]
voice this is
perhaps not quite as embarrassing as the
bdsm dog fetishist that biden tapped for
a federal post a few months ago but it's
pretty close
not surprisingly nina is also a
proponent of the words are violence
school of thought she has a book coming
out apparently called how to be a woman
online
don't ask her to define what a woman is
though i mean she's just the
informations are she's not a biologist
and she tweeted this excerpt from the
book
quote
men burst violently into your mentions
and your life like the kool-aid man
demanding your attention hawking
opinions that they believe are
unarguably manifestly correct and
indispensable
violently
yes men are committing violence by
responding to your tweets
sounds a bit like taylor lorenz this is
a common theme
and this is men of course just men men
men only women never do this but men
also commit the sin of
thinking their opinions are correct now
never mind that literally every human on
earth thinks their opinions are correct
this is this is an accusation made
against me all the time oh matt you
always act like you think your opinions
are correct well of course if i didn't
think they were correct they wouldn't be
my opinion that by definition it's
something that i think is correct
perhaps most importantly of all though
nina who will be in charge of
identifying and censoring disinformation
has already made clear
what the term disinformation means to
her it means any information that is
politically inconvenient to democrats
which is why she labeled the hunter
laptop uh story disinformation back in
2020. she was one of like every other
democrat saying that was disinformation
turns out it was 100 true
that point about the hunter biden laptop
story was made to jen pasake during the
white house press briefing yesterday and
here's how she responded to that listen
she had previously called the hunter
biden laptop a trump campaign product um
seeming to discredit its validity or
validity of reporting surrounding that
um
how can can you assuage concerns of
people who are looking at this person
who's been appointed to this position
and wondering if she's going to be able
to accurately
judge misinformation now that a lot of
that reporting has been
proven to be
factual in some ways well i don't have
any comments on the laptop but what i
can tell you is that it sounds like the
objective of the board is to prevent
disinformation and misinformation from
traveling around the country in a range
of communities i'm not sure who opposes
that effort
she doesn't have any comments about the
laptop angle which is that's the
question right so i i love that from jen
pasake when someone asks a question and
her response is well i don't have any
comments about the question you just
asked so instead i'll make a point
that's irrelevant
she says the board will prevent
disinformation and misinformation from
traveling around the country in a range
of communities and she's not sure who
opposes that effort well many of us do
and let me explain why
first of all note how they are calling i
think this is important okay they are
calling it the disinformation board and
not the misinformation board
now even that small nuance is
significant because it adds an extra
layer of editorializing
misinformation is simply information
that's wrong
disinformation is wrong is information
that's wrong intentionally
so all disinformation is misinformation
but not all misinformation is
disinformation
this information is when there's an
intentional there's a there's an intent
to deceive
the government now has claimed the
authority not only to be the arbiter of
which information is correct and
incorrect but also of the motivations
behind the people spreading the alleged
incorrect information
when you call something disinformation
you are claiming to know both that the
information is wrong and also why it's
wrong
this is the power the bible
administration is claiming for itself
and it it can't end well i mean it's
designed to not end well it never does
end well when a government declares
itself the final judge of truth which is
not the government's job
it's also not the government's job to
control the spread of information
it's supposed to control other things
and the spreads of spread of other
things like um immigration crime okay
those are there's a two big ones that it
should be trying to control
but this regime has little interest in
that
to this regime the greatest enemy is not
crime not anything like that it's
information
and because we live in the information
age
when the average person processes more
information in a day than previous
generations may have encountered in a
year or a decade
that means that the efforts to control
and stifle information will have to have
to be far-reaching and severe and
oppressive
just think about what tyrannical regimes
in the past have done to control the
flow of information before the internet
before me uh modern media
now think about what this one will have
to do given how ubiquitous information
is
now the truth is that they will not be
able to staunch the flow completely or
monitor all of it though they will no
doubt try they're not going to be able
to do it ultimately
the most effective tactic they can take
and have take and have already taken
against inconvenient information which
again is what they mean by
disinformation
there's the actual definition of
disinformation which is incorrect
information meant to deceive but um
that's the actual definition but for
them that's not what it really is it's
this is this is inconvenient information
but the the main tactic here is to
convince people
not to trust their own powers of
perception their own common sense
we saw this we see this all the time
with the left we saw it all throughout
covid trust the experts they said even
if the experts contradict themselves 10
times in the same sentence still just
accept whatever is the most recent thing
the experts have said
lots of people sadly are not only
willing to do this but they find
i think some comfort in it
the the fire hydrant of information
gushing directly into your brain can get
exhausting and overwhelming at times and
after a while people look to outsource
the task of processing and forming
conclusions to some sort of outside
authority
government's more than happy to provide
that service
now it's created a whole department for
that express purpose
don't bother thinking they say we'll
take care of that we'll tell you what to
think
and then they'll pat you on the head and
give you a lollipop send you on your way
the government has already infiltrated
nearly every aspect of your life
the last thing it can take a hold of is
your mind
if you let it
which you shouldn't
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know with mother's day coming just
around the corner it's time to start
thinking about what you want to do to
make your mom feel special i've been um
trying to think about what i want to
give my mom this mother's day season and
all i can think about is the time where
i refuse to fix her vhs player over this
past holiday season
and um now i'm not gonna apologize for
that because i refuse to apologize for
anything never apologize to the
pitchfork mob
even when your own mother is in that mob
but instead i'm going to give my mom
something that she'll be thanking me for
i'm gonna give her a reason to throw
away that vhs player once and for all
with legacy box legacy box is the best
company out there when it comes to
digitally preserving all of your
sentimental but outdated belongings
that's why they've helped millions of
people digitize their belongings over
the past decade just send legacy box all
your video tapes film reels and photos
and their team of over 200 trained
technicians will hand digitize
everything you can track their progress
along the way with their online tracking
system and once they're done they'll
send you all of your original copies
along with a digital copy stored on a
thumb drive the cloud or dvd now uh my
mom's not gonna have to worry about
having a working vhs player anymore and
she can show all my embarrassing photos
and uh videos to my wife easily over the
holidays which she's already done many
times you could do the same for your mom
this mother's day by visiting
legacybox.com walsh right now to get 60
off your order that's legacybox.com
walsh
all right you probably already have
noticed i'm sure there's a comments many
comments um
because people in the comments i've
discovered love nothing more than to
comment on my wardrobe and shame me for
it well i've dressed up a little bit i
got the jacket on
decided to class things up because i'm a
number one best-selling
amazon author now and this is how you
have to dress no actually the truth is
that um my shirt was wrinkled
and i didn't feel like ironing it so i
just put the jacket on like that's the
only time you'll catch me dressing
well as if it's just out of pure
laziness
um okay i want to start with this
because we're just talking about
disinformation and here's a great
example of it
and this is disinformation right so that
is incorrect information that's
intentional
a judicial nominee named nusrat
chowdhury was in front of the
senate committee yesterday
and i want you to listen to this
exchange
about
one piece of
alleged information that turned out not
to be correct but um listen to this
this is a really simple question
councilman do you believe
that cops kill unarmed black men in
america every single day you said it at
princeton
senator i said it in my role as an
advocate oh okay you didn't mean it
senator i said it in my role as an
advocate to make a rhetorical point
so so when you say something is that's
incorrect it's okay to excuse it by
saying oh i was being an advocate what
do you believe do you personally believe
that cops
kill unarmed black men every single day
in america senator i believe law
enforcement have an important and
challenging job in this country that's
not what you said though council
senator i say before you hear today that
i do believe law enforcement have a
difficult and challenging job and i also
understand the difference i just think
that's an extraordinary statement to
make with no data to back up
no none whatsoever
there's no basis for you saying that
and you knew it then and you know it now
how can one possibly believe that you're
going to be unbiased on the federal
bench
senator i believe my record shows that i
have worked collaboratively with law
enforcement in boston chicago
mississippi and milwaukee to solve
complex problems to promote
constitutional effective and your record
shows that you believe cops
are guilty until proven innocent
your record shows that if a cop
if if if if a cop shoots a criminal it's
the cops fault
and if a criminal shoots a cop it's the
gun's fault
i've read your record
i've read your record miss murr and i
don't appreciate you not answering the
question straight up i would respect you
a lot more if you just tell us what you
believe and not try to hide it
yeah this is really perfect because it
shows again that's this is this is
that's disinformation she claimed
um in the past that cops are shooting
unarmed black men every single day in
this country which is not even
within the ballpark of anything that
resembles the truth
as we've gone over before you look at
the actual numbers of unarmed shootings
of both black and white suspects it um
very rarely happens
you could say that it almost never
happens when compared to the number of
interactions that law enforcement have
and the number of arrests that they make
and then you take a percentage how many
uh result in the shooting of an unarmed
person it's like
point zero zero bunch of zero is one
percent
um
extremely rare
and certainly not every day
and then even when you if you were to
just bear down and look at the unarmed
shootings you find that even a good
portion of those are not actually
unarmed because maybe somebody's in a
car trying to run cops over
i think
in no sense can we if you've got a you
know
a
if you're driving your weapon this big
metal contraption you're trying to like
a battering ram drive right into someone
it's hard to see how that would count as
unarmed
so unarmed shootings are very very rare
and then
um
a good portion of the actual alarm
shootings aren't actually unarmed as it
turns out and then even the ones where
the where the suspect actually has no
weapon at all even most of those
shootings end up being justified because
you'll find out that a lot of those
cases there's a there's you know the
suspects trying to take the weapon from
the cop that sort of thing michael brown
that's what that was
and yet this judge said that this
happens every single day that's
disinformation she admits that she
admitted right there in that exchange
that it was disinformation though she
didn't say the word but she admitted it
was disinformation because she admitted
that she knew that was wrong she didn't
say oh you know i thought that
um but i didn't look into it and i was
just mistaken
that would be bad enough but instead she
says i was just trying to make a
rhetorical point um translation i knew
it was wrong but it was it's a it's a
helpful talking point and so i said it
anyway otherwise known as lying
now the disinformation board
for the department of homeland security
is that the kind of disinformation that
they're going to
address
i mean you would think if they were
actually concerned about disinformation
especially harmful disinformation it's
hard for me to think of
a type of disinformation
that has done more harm to this country
over the last five years than exactly
that that cops are out
prowling about hunting down
um unarmed black men and murdering them
in cold blood like of all the the
disinformation that we encounter it's
hard for me to think of something that's
been more harmful than that as it has
led to countless riots billions of
dollars in damages dozens of people dead
entire police stations burned to the
ground all on
the strength
of this disinformation all fueled by
this disinformation
but something tells me the
disinformation board they're not going
to be concerned about that
even though this is law enforcement
department of homeland security
you'd think that they'd be concerned
about disinformation against law
enforcement but no they're not they're
not
um
staying in the buy administration let's
go all the way to the top supposedly the
top biden himself so we see these you
know you see these every single day
clips like this abide in losing his mind
it does it just it gets worse every time
and this is
as bad as we've seen uh but here it is
listen
uh that will enhance our underlying
effort to accommodate the russian
oligarchs and make sure we take their
take their their ill-begotten gains
we're going to accommodate them
we're going to seize their yachts their
luxury homes and other ill-begotten
gains
of putin's kleptocracy
yeah
kleptocracy and clip the guys who are
the kleptocracies
but these are bad guys
oh my gosh
the guys who are the kleptocracies
kleptomaniacs i think is the word he's
going for and uh most people are
focusing on that part of it but
also what is he talking about we're
going to accommodate them that's not
that's not the word you're looking for
you're looking for the opposite of that
we're going to accommodate the russian
oligarchs
i think you mean you're not going to
accommodate them
i think that's what you're trying to say
he's uh
the pres it's not just the president is
losing his mind or his mind is
deteriorating or anything like it's like
he has lost his mind he does not have
one right now he's fully senile and
everyone in the whole world knows it
including our enemies and this is what
we're supposed to just live with for the
next two years
um i also want to play this for you kind
of moving on um staying within
democratic politics though ilhan omar
and we've heard about biden's plan his
hail mary pass the buying
administrations well we can't talk about
first of all we can't talk about biden
doing anything anymore his plans
anything he's got no he's an empty
vessel completely
but the bite administration anyway is
planning this hail mary pass right
before the midterms to try to buy some
votes because they're drowning in the
polls and so they're talking about
student loan forgiveness here's ilhan
omar
outside the capitol with some activists
calling for that kind of forgiveness
we are here to tell the president that
with the stroke of a pen
he can
and should and must
cancel
student debt period
we have 45 million people in this
country who are shackled
with student debt you have to realize
that's 45 million people
who are putting off the opportunity to
start that business they want it to
start
it is 45 million people who are putting
off the opportunity to start the family
they want to start that is 45 million
people
45 million people now
even if that was all true it does not
address
the main objection to so-called student
loan forgiveness otherwise known as
student loan transferal from the person
who took out the loan and forcing people
who didn't take out the loan to pay for
it but she doesn't begin to address
the actual argument against it now all
she's talking about is how difficult it
is to have the debt and how how painful
it is and all that like no one is no
one's arguing that point it's not fun to
have debt
no one's saying otherwise
um
but she doesn't address the argument
against it which is that okay
someone's going to be paying these loans
off
and so either it is going to be the
person who agreed to take out the loan
and purchase the product and has the
product they purchased with that loan
or you're going to force people who
didn't take out the loan to pay for it
you're going to saddle it someone
saddled with the burden it's either them
so either the person took out the law of
the person or people who didn't
the argument against student loan
forgiveness is that
people who didn't take out loans
shouldn't have to pay them simple as
that
you know you don't have to go beyond it
now as it happens what she said what she
actually said is also not true by the
way she said 45 million people have
student loan debts and they're you know
these are 45 million people putting off
starting businesses and starting
families and all the rest of it um
a great number of these people probably
most of them in fact are not putting off
living there's no reason why you should
put off living your life because you
have debt
uh
my wife had student loan debt and we
still got married
and um i have been pa i as the person
didn't go to college have been paying
off my wife's student loans do you think
i have fun doing that you think you
think i enjoy that
no but she's my wife this is my family
i'm not gonna go to anybody else and say
i
i would be ashamed as a man i would be
ashamed as a man
to go and try to enlist
or even worse force someone else to take
on my financial responsibilities
i wouldn't want to force anyone to take
my financial responsibilities even less
would i want to force anyone to take on
my wife's financial responsibilities
that's my that's that's for me
i'm the breadwinner in the family so i
will take care of that
it's it's disgraceful
as a man especially it's disgraceful to
be sitting there whining
someone i don't want to pay this off
someone take care of it
be a man
what is wrong with you
don't tell me that i can't do anything
yes you can
i mean it's oh and i get i guarantee you
one thing all these people say
oh because my student loan debts i can't
do this i can't do that
how many streaming services are they
subscribed to i want to know that
how often do they get the updated iphone
you know you can still do pretty much
anything you want to do even with the
financial debt it's just a matter of
what are your priorities
um one other political story here that i
thought was interesting this is from the
washington free beacon says arizona's
democratic senator kristen cinema likes
to brag that her cleavage has an
extraordinary persuasive effect on some
of her republican colleagues according
to a new book from new york times
reporters jonathan martin and alexander
burns cinema
who has emerged as an obstacle to the
most radical parts of president joe
biden's legislative agenda boasts to
colleagues and aides of using her looks
to get her way with republicans
cinema they say joked with democrats
about how easy it was for her to charm
republican men
and boasted knowingly to colleagues and
aides that her cleavage had an
extraordinary persuasive effect on the
uptight man of the gop
now
i read this and um
i'm not exactly sure
how this is breaking news or news at all
but i did take note of one thing that's
kind of interesting
i note how
her cleavage apparently has no impact at
all on democrat men
what does that imply i wonder
no you've got cory booker there saying
you have no power here woman
um
i mean it could imply that they just
take their jobs a lot more seriously or
you know something else
different tastes i guess
uh let's play a game here this is a game
called owned and not owned so first
here's a viral clip when went real viral
yesterday and um once again
the left is claiming
that ben shapiro
was owned and destroyed and exposed
during a q a by uh
with a college student
and we heard about this a couple weeks
ago
ben shapiro was trending again and and
uh and the claim was that he had been
owned and destroyed and we played that
clip and it really kind of came up short
media matters hall monitor jason
campbell posted this clip and
said this is absolutely amazing you have
to watch it in two minutes all of ben
shapiro's anti-woke tirades are just
destroyed
and like i said this one really viral
and this is the
the left
seems to be the
um pretty wide agreement
that ben shapiro was totally destroyed
by this let's listen and see how that
destruction sounded
so if the idea is that
history has consequences of course
that's true that's not what you have
that is not wokeness what what can it
suggest is that fundamental institutions
in
i
america
i ran elizabeth warren's campaign i
helped organize her volunteers around
here
[Applause]
i am
i am a representative of workness
and that's just this is all it is well i
mean
like i mean i
i you know i hope that when i went to go
get my first tattoo the guy had
lightning bolts and 88s tattooed on his
neck and as a jewish person um that's
really messed up it's basically a threat
there are there are racist people who
exist the argument that you're making
and i'm going to close with this because
this is going in weird directions and i
don't really know it's not i don't know
i don't really want to know just hold up
a second this is
now it's time for me to respond because
i let you say okay i'll let you respond
but no no no not but now's my turn you
you are not characterizing what i'm
saying accurately now it's now it's my
turn your your definition is inaccurate
the reason your definition is inaccurate
is because any sentient human being
would acknowledge that history has
consequences right but if the idea is
but that's not what vocalism is vocalism
is a different thing vocalism suggests
that all inequalities of today are
attributable to not only historic
injustices but also continuing
injustices in the now and that all
disparities
discriminate but not just that
conservative is the only person not just
i want to know why why is it that
i i would let that uh keep playing but
there that's it that's the whole that's
the whole clip now i know you might say
say that i'm biased and uh i kind of
have to
defend ben i don't have to now it's true
that he if he actually was totally
destroyed by a college student um
i probably wouldn't play it on the show
that is true
but then i just wouldn't play it i
wouldn't i just would not acknowledge it
at all probably
um
but i'm you know when it would be
impressive
so anytime i see one of these things
trend a college student destroys
benchmark i i always watch because i'm
like okay well let's see if he actually
does it because that would be impressive
and there's just nothing there his he
was just he destroyed ben shapiro by
pointing out
that he met a tattoo artist with an
offensive tattoo and he worked on
elizabeth warren's campaign what
first of all how are either especially
the the second thing working elizabeth
warren's campaign how is that something
to brag about in the first place i think
you actually lose the argument
from the get-go by pointing that out but
i don't even know what that's supposed
to prove exactly
there's no
there was no there was no argument
presented nothing at all
and there wasn't even an argument
presented by ben shapiro because he
didn't get a chance to speak because he
kept getting cut off
and this is this is the point
is that
the guy the kid
was able to successfully prevent ben
shapiro from making a point by
filibustering and talking over him
and on the left now that's what they
consider owning and destroying
they're not even pretending anymore that
they're going to present arguments and
defeat you
you know on the battlefield of ideas
that way by presenting better ideas and
defending them not even pretending it
what they're going to do instead is just
stop you from talking
and if they can do that then you've been
obliterated
so that was supposed to be owning that
was not
here's what owning sounds like this is
democrat representative
jeffries
um at a different committee hearing i
want you to just
we don't need a lot of setup here i just
want you to listen to this exchange
listen
uh mr powell letter you've
echoed a similar sentiment i think your
quote is many on the left hate justice
thomas because he is a black
conservative
who has never bowed to those who demand
that he must think a certain way because
of the color of his skin what evidence
do you have to support that
uh incendiary charge
when chairman
benny thompson calls him an uncle tom
because of his views on voter id and
affirmative action when in fact more
black americans support voter id and
with respect to affirmative action in
college education they're 62 percent
opposed to it so so that is the most
vile disgusting thing you can say and
and and so yes
you're claiming my time yes there are a
lot of vile disgusting things that can
you just ask me for an example the
notion that that is
right when some members on this side of
the aisle and others have been
called the n word throughout different
points of our life belies uh the point
that you have a particular bias
uh and it's an overstatement which is
not surprising when you look at the
balance of your testimony and if
chairman benny thompson uh has an
observation to make uh he's entitled to
free speech you apparently believe that
jenny thomas regardless of how many
conflicts
she has is entitled to home political
opinions
uh as well
can i give you another example no
no you can't you can't
okay that's what
destroying somebody actually sounds like
um
that's that's what it is jeffrey says
can you give one example
this this terrible terrible charge that
people democrats have been racist
against uh justice thomas give us one
example of this okay well um here's a
guy who called him an uncle tom well uh
yeah but that's uh people have said
worse things and free speech okay i'll
give you another example no no we'll
just stop there
that's
uh it's a total humiliation you know and
that's and this is one thing i'm not a
lawyer but um
one thing i have learned just from
watching the lawyer shows
is that uh and i think it's something
you could probably take with you in in
life especially in debates is
never ask a question that you don't know
the answer to um especially in a
situation like this that's
it as a lawyer in court also in a debate
you want to pose a question to somebody
that you don't already know the answer
to it in this case
he didn't know the answer and he was
completely embarrassed i mean he's
embarrassed by any objective standard
but of course as a democrat it really
just doesn't matter at all
one last thing is from pink news lesbian
visibility week founder linda riley has
slammed jk rowling as the perfect
example of how not to be an ally
lesbian visibility week which celebrates
lesbians and honors all queer women and
non-binary folk within the lgbtq
community began on monday um but uh so
happy lesbian visibility week i don't
know i forgot i totally forgot to
mention it
um
and i think actually in fact the the
fact that um during lesbian visibility
week
the number one book in the country is an
lgbt children's book i think is just
phenomenal it's fantastic
but jk rowling decided to mark the
occasion by saluting the resilience and
courage of her inspirational friend lgb
alliance co-founder allison bailey
ballot bailly a lawyer is currently
suing lgbt rights charity stonewall and
her former employer garden court
chambers for discrimination
and um anyway then the budget left us
came after jk rowling for
speaking out about lesbian visibility
week now here's the
kind of funny thing about this is that
um of course
in reality all of these
various
as we went over back what it was try
there was trans visibility week that was
just two weeks ago
and i went over really a partial list of
all the days and weeks set aside on the
calendar to celebrate lgbt people and
there are just dozens and dozens
and it's all completely silly and
ridiculous
there really you shouldn't require any
day on the calendar not even one to
celebrate your
sexuality
and it's a very weird thing in general
to have days like that celebrating that
aspect of
of somebody but
as it happens
you know um actually
as much as the left likes to claim that
they're being erased you're erasing me
lesbians actually are the category of
lesbian
is in fact
in reality
being erased and if you if you follow
the demographic trends
in another
30 40 years they're they just won't
exist anymore
and you look at the younger generations
gen z and millennials
um
while lgbt identification has
skyrocketed and trans identification
skyrocketed lesbian identification has
fallen off of a cliff and why is that
well it's because
um
every
girl
every woman
who in the past
would have
identified themselves as a lesbian now
they're being told that oh no you're
actually a man
you're not a lesbian you're actually a
not only man you're a straight man it
turns out
so this is if you want to talk about
conversion therapy
this is the really the only kind of
conversion therapy that goes on
you know on top of the most insidious
form which is in general the way that
that kids are recruited into the
lgbt fold but here's conversion therapy
essentially what the left is doing is
they're taking lesbian women and they
are converting them into straight men or
trying to anyway
so that's what's happened
let's get now to the comment section
[Music]
populist puerto ricans says i agree with
everything you said about the college
treadmill we really need to start
bringing back vocational schools and
help kids get apprenticeships let them
figure out what they like in high school
and if they want to go on to higher
learning great if not they'll at least
have a solid foundation with which to
start their lives yes this is one of the
solutions to the college debt crisis
there is no real solution that's going
to erase the past because this is one of
the harshest lessons of life is that you
cannot undo what has been done in the
past you can't really undo it all you
can try to do is shirk your
responsibilities and pass the buck on to
somebody else which you shouldn't do
but going forward this is a solution to
college debt crisis which is to stop
sending all these kids into into college
and this is one
alternative vocational schools
apprenticeships that sort of thing
but really
uh
right out of high school
like
it's just almost
no kids right out of high school should
be going to college almost none
even out of out of all the kids like
almost all the kids who are in college
right now shouldn't should actually
should not be there only a small
minority should actually be there
and of that minority only a small
minority of that minority should go
right out of high school
because even most of them would benefit
from just taking a couple of years
there's just no reason to do it
of course we know why the universities
want to encourage that because they
there's a financial motive there and
they don't want i mean just think about
this why don't the universities want
your
your child
to graduate high school and then go do
something else for a couple years and
then go to college why don't they want
that because they're afraid that if you
go and you do that you might discover
that you don't need to go to college at
all they don't want you to discover that
there's no advantage that i can see
really at all
to going to college right out of high
school there's no reason to do it who is
what is it a race who are you racing
you got your whole life in front of you
so
take a couple of years you're still
you're still young like there's there's
really nothing bad that can happen out
of going to college when you're 21 god
forbid or 22.
you go at any time i could still go to
college if i wanted to
which at this point if i did it would
only be just because it's funny
maybe that's my maybe that's my next act
of trolling is to
go to college
um
let's see
rachel says what do you think of the
lilly peters story should should the boy
be charged as an adult
um i have not read
very much into this story mainly because
it's so horrifying that it's uh
the kind of story that's just difficult
to read
but from what i understand about this
story lily peters is a 10 year old girl
who was murdered
um and as it turns out she was strangled
and sexually assaulted
in the woods
and then it it turns out that
a 14 year old boy is guilty of this
crime
and is being charged as an adult so i
guess that's the debate is should you
charge 14 year old boys as adults
and what i would say to that is um
in the vast majority of cases no you
shouldn't charge 14 year olds as adults
because they're 14.
but in a case like this yeah absolutely
because this is just
if you're already at this point as a 14
year old
society can never trust you again you
could never be trusted in society ever
again
there are things that a 14 year old can
do not many but there are things a 14
year old can do
that i think just
tragically on so many levels disqualify
them from ever participating in human
society ever again and this is one of
those things
e um says as an amazon employee myself
seeing the book at work was the
highlight of my day it doesn't really
say a lot but
for what it's worth
uh you know i have heard
some some you know
there certainly are people within amazon
and that's how we got a hold of these
video clips in the first place
who are still on team sanity and i
appreciate that
uh
let's see another comment says talking
about
megan fox she says she says that uh her
son wears dresses like he chooses them
but i highly doubt he picked them out
himself from the store who bought him
the dresses megan no one buys their son
a dress unless they want him to wear a
dress which to me
says she's a groomer uh yes absolutely
that's that's the thing that's why
that's why i say it's one of the reasons
why i say
there's no there's really no such thing
as a six-year-old trans kid
or a six-year-old who chooses to be
non-binary or whatever because that's
not on so many levels that's not a
choice a child can make and especially
they can't go out
if they have female clothing it's
because you went out and bought it for
them which apparently megan fox did at a
very young age but remember
remember
she only did this because she sensed
when her child was in the womb
that uh that he was going to be
non-binary she sensed it
i mean usually we're told from the left
that children in the womb are not even
human
unless they're non-binary or trans in
which case they are i guess that's the
one loophole
you know at the daily wire we've started
our own publishing wing called dw books
and we're proud to publish books that
actively fight the left's monopoly on
storytelling like fiery but mostly
peacefully 20 20 riots and the
gaslighting of america by julio rosas in
it rosas exposes the black lives matter
riots that broke out across the country
in the aftermath of george floyd's death
for the sham that they wore rosas who
was reporting from the ground gives
first-hand experience and illuminates
the media's attempts to convince
americans that the fatal and destructive
riots were somehow peaceful check out
the trailer
the media gaslight the american people
for all of 2020 as the riots unfolded
they did not give you the full story
i was there
joe floyd kyle rittenhouse rachard books
jazz in seattle i saw all the riots with
my own eyes windshields being smashed
giant rocks that were being from
businesses that were starting to be
looted the crowd started to become
hostile
all the cops were trapped and surrounded
police were being ordered to to retreat
i experienced the tear gas i experienced
the smoke this was very real to me
the mainstream media they were trying to
call them protests cnn with that chiron
saying fiery but mostly peaceful they're
trying to push a narrative of don't
believe your lying eyes because they
were trying to appease a very dedicated
antifa movement that's there we read my
book fiery but mostly peaceful you will
get the full story you will learn what
actually happened during the riots of
2020 and what the media did not want to
tell you by my book fiery but mostly
peaceful everywhere books are sold
the book's available for pre-order on
amazon or anywhere you buy books online
so go pre-order your copy today now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so today we're going to once again pick
on a fellow youtuber who is in dire need
of a good old-fashioned debunking
the channel is called powered by
rainbows so that should give you some
idea of what we're getting ourselves
into powered by rainbows provides we're
told in the channel description weekly
lgbtq education
the guy in the video we're gonna watch
wears a rainbow tie-dye shirt with the
words professor pride on it now i don't
think that's his official academic title
though i wouldn't be surprised if
universities are actually giving out
those kinds of professorships i don't
know the particular video we're
interested in today is about the alleged
science of being transgender as it says
in the title now this has been viewed
half a million times has 7 000 comments
most of them from people who say that
the content was very encouraging and
validating for them
that's not a good thing because the
content is also as we'll see completely
misleading dishonest absurd and since
it's validating and affirming people and
falsehood and delusion extremely harmful
the whole video is 23 minutes long i'm
not going to force you to sit through
all that instead we'll we'll take about
five minutes of this
the crux of the whole thing
which purports to offer scientific proof
beyond any shadow of a doubt
that transgenderism is scientifically
valid we'll take that we'll we'll watch
and we'll react uh let's dive right in
the thing you have to understand about
transphobic people is their entire
argument all boils down to one thing
science no matter what argument a
transphobic person might call out in the
middle of their hatred the keystone of
that argument seems to be on a
scientific basis
if you're not familiar with the word
keystone it's a term used in
architecture to describe the central
stone at the summit or the top of an
archway locking the whole arch together
now if only there was a way for us to
remove that keystone and scientifically
prove their cornerstone invalid then
every single one of their arguments fall
apart as a result
and at this point i think you know where
i'm heading with this episode because
luckily for us
science proves that being transgender is
completely valid so let's explain how we
know this
now one of the reasons that i'm
responding to this video is that in
these five minutes we're going to sort
through
nearly every incoherent and fallacious
and fraudulent aspect of gender ideology
is put on display we see it already in
how professor pride has set all this up
in the world he presents there are only
two categories of people even though he
would say that he's he believes in a
non-binary system he actually believes
in a binary system but uh the two
categories of people are those who agree
with him on the topic of sex and
transphobic people that's it
now
he's right at least that the opposing
point of view does all come down to
science there are other elements to it
also gender ideology is not just
factually and scientifically wrong but
also morally abominable as well but the
moral problems all stem from the
falsehood of the ideology and so it does
begin with the science if you can
disprove our scientific argument that
men have penises and women have vaginas
then yes you will have destroyed our
whole position you will have leveled our
fortress with a barrage of facts and
logic we'll be exposed and utterly
defenseless
so
let's see if professor pride can do just
that
the most common argument that
transphobic people will make is that you
were assigned the gender at birth which
you were always meant to be
okay well it's a little bit of a stop
and start here we have to stop it
already because
professor pride packed uh more
falsehoods into those five seconds than
i thought it was physically possible
he's he's sticking with calling us all
transphobes which is false but i'm not
going to point it out every time he does
it because that's all i would be doing
since it's all he does
and then he says that our most common
argument is
quoting him who's who allegedly is
quoting us
you were assigned the gender at birth
which you were always meant to be
no part of that is true
that's not even remotely the argument we
make none of us are saying that
we do not believe that male and female
are assigned at birth
no mere mortal assigns sex at all and
the assigning process if you want to
call it that happens at conception not
birth
also notice how i'm using the word sex
here not gender that's because i reject
the category of gender altogether humans
humans have a sex male or female gender
is a nonsensical arbitrary category
invented by pedophile sexologists in the
1960s so if you want to engage with what
you call the transphobic argument you
would need to begin by defending the
invention of the gender category for
human beings in the first place instead
professor pride just assumes that the
pedophile sexologists were correct takes
it all for granted and charges forward
this makes everything that comes after
this point totally irrelevant because
you cannot assume that we have a shared
fundamental premise here we don't it's
the fundamental premise that we're
fighting about
if you aren't going to defend that and
you're going to base your whole argument
on a premise that you haven't attempted
to defend
then you've already lost
but let's keep listening anyway
as accredited psychiatrist moret altenay
reports we know that after a father's
sperm cell fertilizes an egg in the
mother's womb that embryo starts to
develop specialized genitalia resembling
male or female which genitalia it
develops is determined by the father's
sperm cell but quote the brain and the
body can go in different directions
gender is not only in our genitalia
there is something in the brain that
determines gender so technically
speaking this argument saying you were
born with the gender you were meant to
be
is correct because your brain was born
the way it is and your brain doesn't
switch out with someone else's but
gender is not determined by having a
penis or a vagina downstairs it's
determined in your brain
now notice what he's done here it's the
same thing that gender ideologues always
do though these people claim that sex
and gender are two different things he
conflates them whenever it suits his
argument here he says that gender is
determined by both your genitals and
your brain you'll note how he never says
the word sex at all at any point in the
argument he's presenting
but if gender and by that he means sex
even if he doesn't say it is determined
by both your genitals and your brain
then why would a man who is male in his
genitals but female in his brain
allegedly be a female i mean if you've
proven anything there and you haven't
proven a damn thing of course at all but
even if you did this is an argument i
suppose for non-binary for people who
are in between or both or whatever it's
not an argument for women with penises
of course he's actually right
that gender read sex is determined in
your brain as well i mean your brain is
part of the picture
that's because your brain is part of
your body and if you are a man then your
whole body is male every part of it
every cell
a man with a male body automatically has
a male brain because the brain is part
of the body and it makes no logical
sense whatsoever to say that part of a
man's body is actually a woman to speak
of a woman's brain in a man's body is
exactly the same as speaking of a
woman's arm on a man's body
now some men especially liberal men may
have what appear to be women's arms but
in fact if they're men
then their arms are men's arms
automatically despite appearances
the same is true of brains indeed the
very definition of the term man's brain
would have to be the brain which exists
inside a man's head that's the only
thing a man's brain is
now professor pride's argument is
logically invalid in about 75 different
ways so far as we've seen
but let's go for 76 because here he's
going to tell us about a scientific
study which proved he says that
transgenderism is valid now he never
bothers to explain what he means by
valid
but you know we can only focus on so
many fallacies at a time here so let's
listen in this study the 2600
participants were put in mri machines to
scan their brains and record brain
activity
the researchers also had cisgender men
and cisgender women go through the same
test
and finally researchers compared the
scans on the left side of your screen
you can see the brain activity of a
cisgender male adult
on the right side of your screen you can
see the brain activity of a transgender
male adult but you'll notice they look
nearly identical and that's something
researchers found in every single case
out of the 2600 participants
their study concluded that transgender
males have brain activity almost
identical with cisgender males and
wildly different from the brain activity
from cisgender females even though they
were assigned female at birth of their
genitalia they also determined that
transgender females have brain activity
almost identical with cisgender females
and massively different from the brain
activity from a cisgender males even
though they were born male at birth with
their genitals in other words the brain
is 100 percent backing the hypothesis
that your gender is identified in your
brain not your genitalia and it proves
beyond a shadow of a doubt that being
transgender is completely valid
according to science
okay where to begin uh let's try to
break this down he does go on to mention
one other similar study that did the
same sort of thing and had similar
results he claims and that's it two
studies comparing brain scans these
studies prove beyond a shadow of a doubt
that transgenderism is valid whatever
that's supposed to mean according to
science he also says that the brain
scans were nearly identical between
trans people and the sex they identify
as and that this again proves absolutely
without question that he's right about
everything
though he does at the end
say this listen
the limitations of these studies are
endless
as dr altanae says some of the brain
scans show people are somewhere between
sharing characteristics of both male and
female brain scans and this
scientifically proves that gender exists
on a spectrum
wait what i thought you just said the
studies prove your point beyond a shadow
of a doubt now you're admitting the
studies had endless limitations and i
thought you said the brain scans were
identical now you say that some of the
brain scans weren't identical but were
somewhere in between which is it i don't
answer that i know the answer the study
said whatever you need them to have said
in order to prove whatever point you're
currently trying to make this is how the
gender ideologues approach literally
everything including life itself the
truth is whatever they need it to be in
any given moment is as simple as that
and what about these studies
he says they looked at brain activity
what sort of brain activity which
activities the human brain can do like
10 000 trillion calculations a second
the brain's doing a whole lot of
activities all the time saying that the
brain activity between two people is the
same
means almost nothing or else it means
that the two people are what identical
clones of each other created in a
laboratory somewhere
no what professor pride means is that if
you take a scan which examines a small
limited subset of some brain activity
and you compare a quote trans woman to a
quote cis woman the scan will look
similar sometimes but not always
okay and
notice how he put up on the screen an
alleged example of a scan of a quote
trans woman and a quote cis woman and
then gives his audience few of whom are
neurologists supposed presumably about
12 seconds to analyze them and come to
the conclusion that eureka they look
kind of the same
of course nobody knows what they're
looking at or what it means and he also
didn't let us see the control group
the scan from this trans woman quote
unquote and this quote cis woman are
similar but what about a scan of a man
who doesn't identify as a woman how
similar would that look
i'm betting it would be pretty close as
well indeed i'm betting that the mri
scans of nearly every human brain on
earth would look pretty similar to most
people
especially if you don't know what you're
looking at or how to read the scans
what does any of this prove
well nothing at all the most i could
possibly prove and i'm skeptical it even
proves this
is that some elements of the brain's
activity in a man who desires to be a
woman will mirror to a limited extent
the activity of a woman who actually is
a woman
now this if true is not surprising and
in no way even begins to invalidate the
claim that men are not women at most i
mean at the absolute most it would be a
somewhat interesting insight into the
powerful psychological placebo effect
that occurs when a man who wants to be a
woman is validated as a woman
it can't get within spinning distance of
proving what professor pride wanted to
prove
and i've said all this so far and
somehow i haven't even made the most
important point which is this
he says that a man's female identity is
valid
if the man's brain scan looks similar to
a female's
but what if it doesn't
if a transgender went in for a brain
scan and you found that his scan looks
more like his biological sex
would you then tell him that he's not
really a woman and his trans identity is
invalid
no you wouldn't
you certainly wouldn't
because all of this is irrelevant to my
argument and also to your own
so in summary your argument is false
self-contradictory built on a false
premise misleading cherry-picked and
totally irrelevant to the claim that
you're actually trying to defend
otherwise
great stuff
also professor pride you're cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin